yeah good morning good morning good
morning welcome to gratitude livestream
gratitude journal live stream number 24
he was special guest today Alex it's his
birthday today and so you get to do the
best thing in the world yeah work at
Toronto de salsa that's what I'm talking
right it's gonna be on the gratitude
yeah that's good too um yeah you should
work extra hard on your birthday that's
that's going to go home and attacked
good crush yeah ok so we do three things
that were grateful for because the world
needs happier and more grateful
entrepreneurs we are we are unhappy and
we want to push and we want to do more
and at the same time we're extremely
paper we already have because most you
guys watching already have more than
most people in the world and so just
appreciating that so I'm going to share
three things I'm going before Alex will
share three things he's good before
we'll do some shout outs in the chat and
then you guys watching afterwards leave
it down below make it consistent every
day it's not a once a week thing every
day and actually feel it you gotta you
gotta think about the why not just
listed off you got to really feel why
you're grateful to get the emotional
benefits of it so I will start I'm
grateful for this man Alex last night he
covered for me an event the trauma and
salsa which allowed me to go out with
Nina so that was that was a fun night
out Nina was feeling some some stresses
just have not spending time together his
all week has been kind of nuts and so
that was a that was pretty helpful he
also made me a full breakfast look at
this he walks over it gives me a full
breakfast we got a crush on a pizza
thing what is this is this is an
eggplant with some cheese record I'd
Scott it's got some pasta sauce it's
good the legendary Alex eggs yes and
some yogurt yeah so in Alex's birthday I
get breakfast I think think that's
pretty awesome yeah I i give up for my
calls today i've got a bunch of calls i
think i have one or two hang outs after
the
the live stream the legal action work
for this so I don't really know who I'm
talking to or what but I love Thursday's
Thursday's is public facing day I always
good to meet new people and exchange new
ideas so there'll be at least one more
hangout and I hope you guys will join in
on that Jennifer some fun and then last
night I'm grateful for our Nina who gave
me a hand massage to put me to sleep
because we went out to this bubble tea
place that was authentic bubble tea as
she tastes pretty different huh and
she's like I think I think this has like
a lot of caffeine I might keep you up
I'm okay you know bubble tea isn't keep
me up I'll be fine then in line in bed
mmm normal bubble tea doesn't but I feel
like this was authentic bubble tea or
whatever like they put a lot of tea in
and said that she kept me up so she gave
me a hand massage and put me to sleep
pretty quickly after so think you Nina
those are my three okay what you got I
mean I hold on hold i got to stay in the
chat it's alex's birthday not my
birthday no i think most people know
it's my big icy happy birthday heaven oh
ok this is birthday cakes and stuff
happening here but ok good this his
birthday he made me breakfast on his
birthday oh yeah turn 30 that's a big
number this is it so wait I get to it's
fun yeah okay okay so three things I'm
grateful for the first thing I'm
grateful for is being able to work in my
dream job there you go I would never
have imagined that I'd have this
opportunity to love fest here right it
is it is it is it is a romance and a lot
of other things um I wanted to be a cop
I wanted to be a marriage counselor I
want to be a lot of things and then I
threw my passion and hard work of
dancing I'm doing something which
impacts people's lives and just has
changed I've changed more and grown more
oh I guess is the second thing so the
first thing is my dream job second thing
because of my dream job I've grown and
changed and self actualized more and the
year I've been doing this work that I
haven't like a large part of my life
it's kind of crazy I'm constantly
challenged
every day in my life um with with how I
see people how I should treat people how
I should be as a human being and so I'm
super grateful for that that I'm always
growing and the third thing that I'm
grateful for is my fiancee I love her so
much she's done so much for me her
birthday present she got me skydiving
tickets that's been in my bucket list
for a while so she surprised me
yesterday uh with that and she arranged
for two of my friends to join without me
knowing it there's like a lot of Jeff
puppet master lot of back behind the
scenes thing so I'm grateful for her I'm
going for this she's so incredible and
thoughtful and just amazing and has made
my life more enriching and happier you
know we both put each other's number one
Billy in our fiance lcy it's never thing
complet it's complicated really watch
this we might be in trouble it's just
today it's a special day x.x and
proximity and yogurt involved okay let's
quickly go through some of the charity
removal people for all the good and the
bad that happened in my life and Bob did
the point where we're currently em and
meet the person I am today for better
for worse I like that Junior is thankful
for nature and all it freely provides
for Evan the world benefits huge from
loving peeps like him Thank You Man for
fresh haircuts and flirty waitresses for
easy free flowing breath that Zeno's
back number one people's good deeds on
the news we often hear about the bad
things people do but luckily there are
also plenty of people who do good i love
that the freedom i have living in
amsterdam not everyone has that and that
sad makes me extra grateful for what I
have and my ears the body part of the
day zana does a body part of your day my
ears my dad quite my dad has quite some
trouble hearing what people say and
that's super-annoying for both parties
I'm happy I don't have that problem
myself yet listen by the time you get
there they'll be they'll be Austin
second oscillations in solutions the ER
5000
okay baby guys Xena's also i sucked
better than having a long time people
for that as well love it what do we have
what we have happy birthday from lisa
mejia vels pumped to see Alex on there
yay Alex from Zeno jr. eyes Alex well
wow this is a gratitudes chamber came at
the alexandra for alex kay go through
your own spoon follow him on snapchat
you can see all his daily shanigan i
make guest appearances once a week or so
yeah rishi cup TBH hey hey everyone
couple of happy birthday from Kimberly
Owens with a ton of emojis the only
emotion that doubled up was bags of cash
yeah she's sending you bags of cash
thank you think it is the Kimberly and I
deposit that tail bien good morning Zeno
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear Alex I'm Ricky
you lots of no sounds of that millville
happy birthday Alex can't be ungrateful
for beautiful quiet morning coach Bailey
hey vino I'm so happy people now that
I'm living my life by design I'm loving
myself and I'm being present daily I
love that birthday breakfast happy
birthday number one get before waking up
I'm grateful for Evans delicious
breakfast can go yeah I gotta eat it I
love it from the birthday boy Jude I'm
grateful to have the most support and
family who support me in my ups and
downs I love that Colin wow I want
breakfast to go Alex all cats are we
should come Wow Adrian every time we do
you know every time I had some done the
channel gets kind of love and then kind
of feels his head a little bit I still
make sure to forward your comments on
the him yeah thank you you guys can fill
up and I'll beat him back down keep me
humble go to Bailey Cooper before oxygen
people for capitalism all right
beautiful moisture my two-year-old
daughter said she is grateful for mommy
daddy and her big brother I love that uh
kruton grateful for a roof over my head
utiful hobby birthday haven't yes it's
alex's birthday but thank you i'll take
it to you know we can
celebrate Alex birthday Israel puts paw
I read that as chutzpana much it's not a
plug it into a lot of good love Ali
watch then Galway City Ireland feeling
inspired with the channel thank you
ollie coach Bailey happy birthday SI loo
see Lou Lewis a good look for the gifts
that the Most High gave me to become the
business man that I am awesome Jay rises
grapples Anina and authentic bubble tea
the two more happy birthday Evans it's
not my birthday it's his birthday it's
alex's birthday thank you jr eyes for
clarity love that oh just skip the whole
bunch come on see you know who says that
youtube man skips a whole bunch oh we're
going nine ten anyway good will end on
the happy birthday still lots of love
for alex i'll hopefully see you some of
you guys in the last room later on today
i'm going to hop on the twitch do a game
of league of legends and answer your
business questions but if this is the
last time i see you then have an amazing
day continue to believe or belong or
whatever your one where it is i'll see
you soon